[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60,18 nous sommes le jeudi 17 février
voici les titres et des villes où il
fait bon pédaler le baromètre des villes
cyclables 2021 a été dévoilé il ya
quelques jours versailles et magny les
hameaux sont en tête en ile de france
reportage le point également sur le rer
vélo qui entend créer un grand réseau
francilien de pistes cyclables
suite et fin du dossier de la rédaction
consacrée au marché véritable lieu de
rencontres d'histoires et de personnages
hauts en couleur dernier numéro ce soir
au marché de rambouillet qui s'installe
notamment chaque mercredi et samedi
place de la libération et puis château
lieu incontournable du street art deux
des six oeuvres réalisées dans la ville
l'été dernier sont sélectionnés pour les
golden street art 2021 40 fresque en
tout sont en lice les votes du public
sont ouverts jusqu'au samedi 19 février
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
avons appris cette information dans
l'après midi le centre de vaccination de
rambouillet fermera ses portes ce samedi
19 février au soir et décision prise
suite à la baisse constante des rendez
vous ces dernières semaines le site se
tient prêt à rouvrir en cas de rebond
épidémique ducobu 19è les personnes
ayant pris rendez vous après cette date
seront réorientés vers des
professionnels de santé rambouillet qui
rejoint donc saint quentin en yvelines
dans la liste des centres qui vont
fermer le vaccinodromes que vous voyez à
l'image cessera son activité le 25
février
cette nouveauté qui va permettre de
couvrir les besoins en eau potable mais
également en chauffage des habitants de
saint germain en laye cette semaine le
forage de l'albien a été inauguré les
précisions de mathilde franco à
proximité de la chaufferie biomasse le
nouveau forage halal bien de saint
germain en laye à trois objectifs
transférer l'ancien forage situé au pecq
son fourrage est en fait il découle d'un
ancien forage qui existait au pec qui
n'est plus exploité aujourd'hui réaliser
la valorisation thermique de l'eau on
valorise la chaleur 1 l'ol ressort à 28
degrés de ce forage 28 degrés c'est trop
chaud pour être distribués donc nous on
extrait les calories ont fait blesser la
chaleur et cette chaleur récupérée ont
l'art et injecte dans le réseau de
chaleur et sécuriser l'approvisionnement
en eau potable pour les saint germanois
à travers la mise en place de ce forage
halal bien nous maîtrisons 40% de nos
consommations d'eau et c'est très
important
d'avoir des capacités de maîtriser ces
flux parce que c'est aussi la maîtrise
des prix de l'eau plus tard la nappe
phréatique de l'albien est situé à
environ 627 m sous terre le coût total
des travaux s'élève à un peu plus de 5
millions d'euros on est sur un budget
est conséquent avec 5 millions d'euros
de subventions publiques l' agence de
l'eau l'ademe celle agence pour la
maîtrise de l'énergie la région
ile-de-france cas voilà été un
partenaire de de tous les instants et
puis des partenaires économiques parce
que la particularité de ce progrès c'est
que c'est du public et du privé donc la
société saur et puis la banque des
territoires c'est à dire la caisse des
dépôts et consignations qui est
également notre partenaire au capital de
cette société d'économie mixte des âmes
un la chaleur de l'eau permettra de
fournir 6800 mégawattheure de chaleur
aux habitants puis 16 1200 mégawatts
heure en 2024 cette nouvelle source de
chaleur permettra à la ville de saint
germain les d'étendre sa part d'énergie
renouvelable a quasiment 80 %
[Musique]
la fédération des usagers de la
bicyclette a récemment dévoilé son
baromètre des villes cyclables 2021
résultats magny les hameaux est en tête
des communes en ile-de-france pour que
le village obtient-il de bons résultats
éléments de réponse avec célia gars
tsongo mélanie poké bixente mayence
insisté ban et patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
adepte du vélo la famille neuville
empruntent régulièrement cette piste
cyclable de thise au vélo pour aller à
l'école ou quand je fais des activités
des fois on fait des sorties des longues
sorties avec papa maman c'est un peu une
philosophie puis donc du coup ils me
suivent aussi à vélo et pas trop choix
il faut il faut aussi au moment donc ils
sont sur le vélo aussi depuis tout petit
depuis qu'ils ont trois ans et demi ou
quatre ans ils ont appris à faire du
vélo et donc on profite de ce moyen de
transport pour circuler en ville
notamment et puis ceux ci un sport pour
nous d'après le baromètre des villes
cyclables magny les hameaux est la
première commune d'île de france où il
fait bon des pédales et c'est vrai que
la ville se prête bien à la circulation
il ya peu de trafic des voyages
cyclables etc donc c'est on sent en
sécurité et aucun souci
c'est également à vélo qu'est didier et
marlène vont faire les courses a
romainville habitant de magny les
hameaux ils sont habitués de ce maître
de transports doux on est libre on a pas
de parking que la voiture je vais même
en vélo jusqu'à la gare de 50 à 120 seul
fonds
c'est un programme minutes je vais aussi
vite que le bus un trajet de cinq
minutes pour arriver à destination
tous les deux jours le retraité se
déplace à vélo pour les courses les
rendez-vous administratif ou encore se
rendre à la poste sur le chemin grand
qu'on a pris là vous venez le week-end
c'est plein plein plein de gens il vaut
mieux pas prendre la voiture oui c'est
bien parti il ya encore du travail tout
à fait surtout dans la liaison des
pistes cyclables en fait
l'interconnexion des pistes cyclables
des travaux encore à faire dont le maire
est conscient maintenant très clairement
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est les
liaisons vers les autres communes autour
et là il faut que l'ensemble des des
collectivités qui ont ses compétences la
fassent aussi leur travail c'est le cas
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines avec le plan vélo donc qui
vient d'être votée des axes cyclables
notamment avec la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux devraient être
réalisés les travaux du plan vélo de
saint quentin en yvelines débuteront
2023 ou 2024 avant les jo
avec moi par visioconférence philippe
coudène et eric par les membres du
collectif vélos ile-de-france bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir en magny les hameaux
première ville cyclable d'île de france
mais on peut y ajouter aussi la ville de
versailles qui est première pour les
communes de plus de 20 mille habitants
montigny le bretonneux et 2e des l'isi
villacoublay du en cours sont également
bien placé il fait bon pédaler dans les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines et
de versailles grand parc
c'est certain à versailles grand parc en
tout cas à versailles on a en a de
plusieurs communes qui sont qui sont
bien bien placé ya but de les loges en
josas versailles sont certainement des
deals où il fait bon ou pédaler alors
avant de parler du sujet on va parler de
ce sujet on a parlé de ce sujet on va
parler d'un autre sujet pardon voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a invité c'est
un projet d'envergure qui devrait
aboutir des petits bugs techniques c'est
pas grave en 2030 c'est le rer b rer
vélo autrement dit créer un grand réseau
de pistes cyclables franciliens
interconnecté l'existant crée aussi est
de nouvelles voies pour aboutir un tout
cohérent qui ressemblerait à ça on va
voir la carte s'afficher et neuf lignes
650 km de pistes cyclables avec d'ores
et déjà cinq axes prioritaires ciblés à
partir de 2025 c'est un projet de 500
millions d'euros porté par votre
collectif vélos ile de france et soutenu
également par la région ile de france à
hauteur de 300 millions d'euros
shippuden pourquoi c'est un projet qui
fait sens
seïf essence parce qu' ils répondent aux
attentes des cyclistes d'un réseau
structurant et continue si on regarde ce
qu'ils avaient fait à l'existant ou les
pistes cyclables ne serait ce que sur
une carte on voit bien que les
discontinuités sont partout quand on est
sur le terrain
la qualité n'est pas forcément au rendez
vous et ne répond pas forcément aux
besoins du quotidien
le collectif vélos ile-de-france qui
comprend je le rappelle quarante et une
association 160 communes 8000 adhérents
et qui a été créée en mars 2019 a tout
de suite cherché à créer un réseau
structurant structurants confortable le
sécurisent et continue à l'échelle de
l'île de france de manière à créer une
sorte de squelette sur lesquels
viendront s'appuyer d'autres réseaux
plus beaucoup plus locaux comme le des
parcs départementaux ou intercommunaux %
du réseau est déjà existants ça veut
dire qu'il reste plus de la moitié à
accomplir encore
oui c'est qu'on peut
45% ce sont déjà les voies vertes
existantes à ce sont des défis des
endroits où on à pas cher à chercher le
tracé par contre il faudra quand même
travailler sur la qualité et la réponse
au cahier des charges
puisque vous le nôtre est sûre le sur
les documents de la région qui sont
pétition publique
on a un certain standard qui est des
pièces de qualité et qui est certaine
exigence de qui sont fixées par un
cahier des charges spécifique pour le
rer b alors la fibre que des nous vous
êtes en charge de ce projet un revers
vélo plutôt sur le nord des yvelines
eric charles et vous vous êtes plutôt
sur la partie versailles grand parc
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup d'aménagements
à prévoir sur sur ce secteur est ce que
l'existant est déjà conséquent pour ce
projet rer vélo de l'existant n'existe
que dans paris est un petit peu issy les
moulineaux on va faire le tour de la
boucle de la seine parce que la
traversée de boulogne billancourt est
impossible en revanche donc le dès qu'on
va monter sur la d901 dit c'est à dire
qu'il va du pont de sèvres jusqu'à
versailles et ensuite au delà qui
continue vers saint cyr l'école et
trappe on a on a tout à faire c'est à
dire qu'en gros on a défini ce tracé on
pense qu'à la place mal principe de
continuité c'est à dire la chaussée
roulante des voitures en stationnement
la piste cyclable aux normes et ensuite
le trottoir de manière à ce qu on ait
pas de risque de d'interférences avec
les voitures
en stationnement c'est à dire les
ouvertures de portières et c'est donc on
attend une certaine continuité sur un
trash c'est sur le tracé sur lequel on
s'est mis d'accord le problème c'est
qu'il ya encore quelques points
difficiles des points techniquement
impossible où il va pas casser tous et à
viroflay les arcades et
saint cyr l'école où là on a donc à
travailler beaucoup avec la mairie pour
obtenir la solution des embouteillages
voiture qui a actuellement à saint cyr
ce sera les embouteillages ou les vélos
et donc il va falloir faire des choix
difficiles donc des choix encore à faire
quand est-ce qu'on pourrait voir les
premiers aménagements les premières
réalisations c'est sa demande encore un
petit peu de réflexion on l'a bien
compris
oui alors là pour l'instant on a lancé
les phases d'études et
donc qu'ils vont se répartir les
différents maîtres d ouvrage mais à
l'issue des phases d'études ont validé
un trajet qui sera pas totalement
définitif notamment l'articulation du
bas le pont de sèvres jusqu'à issy les
moulineaux où on sait bien que c'est un
noeud de route très compliqué mais pour
le reste on devrait voir les premiers
coups de pioche assez rapidement
peut-être avant les jeux olympiques qui
part tout sera fini ou jeux olympiques
on espère avoir fini en 2025 puisque
nous sommes le héros hervé s'est dotée
la lettre qui est la même que la ligne c
du rer le rer b c de liz est en 1re
phase ii du rer v du réseau carte est
effectivement le code couleur reprend le
code couleur justement du rer a les
trains bien sûr qui circulent en
ile-de-france alors parmi les neuf
lignes à cinq axes prioritaires il y en
a un qui va passer par les yvelines
justement de ces axes prioritaires c'est
celui qui va aller jusqu'à plaisir c'est
bien ça
philippe ou des nouilles peut-être oui
il ya trois ans on a trois lignes qui
sont en cours de
d'études un hallali a un qui fait porte
maillot pontoise qui passe par le nord
des yvelines sur conflans sainte
honorine
morcourt et puis andrésy la c1 la c1 qui
fait issy les moulineaux mort pas en
passant par versailles et puis la b3 qui
pas kiffer porte de châtillon alors
c'est un grand arc de cercle qui fait
tout le sud de la région parisienne et
qui remonte sur plaisir et qui emprunte
un petit bout de vélo de la vélo ceni
pour ceux qui connaissent les axes
prioritaires alors si on en vient
maintenant au nord des yvelines qui est
la partie qui vous concerne le plus même
question que pour eric harley ce qui a
beaucoup d'aménagements à prévoir ou en
inde ou en est-on concrètement
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de travail
qui sont faits dans ce qu'on appelle les
comités dax l'arrêt de la région
pilote et anime des réunions dans
lesquelles se retrouvent toutes les
poules et toutes les parties prenantes
c'est à dire les communautés d'agglo les
villes le département puis certaines
certaines industries qui sont
propriétaires l'eau nf la bnf vous
connaissez le millefeuille administratif
et à chaque fois ça répond à des normes
différentes donc c'est très difficile
quelques fois de mettre tout le monde
d'accord et c'est le rôle de la région
de vérifier qu'il ya bien accord dans
tous les accords complet de tous les
participants pour commencer à faire les
études pratiques donc ça ça c est en
cours sur la ligne à 1 celle qui passe
entre maisons laffitte et et pontoise à
des voisins aussi qui travaillent dessus
et
je pense qu'il y aura un tronçon qui est
en passe d'aboutir et on va
[Musique]
on a on a bon espoir que ce soit faire
dans les deux prochaines années mais oui
c'est quand même c'est quand même des
discussions très très très importante
puisque on prépare le travail pour la
pour la maîtrise d'ouvragé derrière les
discussions qui sont très importantes
pour préparer leur est justement une
dernière question peut-être à vous deux
vous avez bon espoir de voir aboutir
totalement ce projet la région
ile-de-france parle d'une mise en
service petit à petit entre 2025 et ce
jusqu'en 2030 en 2030 on aura un rer
vélo à votre avis complet en ile de
france vous avez bon espoir
oui moi j'ai bon espoir la première
enfin la première phase et est déjà bien
en route avec la région site 80 réunions
c'est quand même un travail monumental
qu'il faut souligner bon pour la
deuxième phase ce sera peut-être plus
compliqué et plus plus on a quand même
un peu de temps devant nous et puis il
ya des faces qu'on peut avancer comme
des parcours comme la scène à vélo par
exemple qui n'attend qui n'attend que
qu'un aménagement qui était assez léger
mais qui est le tracé est déjà fait donc
a priori on peut on peut faire les
parties communes rer b et réseaux
existants
réseau voie verte existants donc on peut
déjà avancer sur certains sujets même
sur la face de la région est prête vous
êtes optimiste également eric harley oui
je suis optimiste parce que en fait les
les mentalités des des citoyens parce
que c'est les mairies sont en général
pro vélo il n'y a pas de problème sauf
très grave et saufs sauf exception
maintenant en revanche les citoyens ma
quand ils voient disparaître des pièces
d'aider des places de stationnement
lorsqu'il voit que l'accès à leur
commerce est plus peur voitures et les
guides doit être à pied ou à vélo ils
ont ils ont des craintes on a des
craintes pour ce qu'on ne connaît pas
alors qu'on est habitué à des choses qui
sont pas forcément bien alors regardez à
nancy par exemple la place stanislas
plein de voitures quel courage politique
il a fallu pour obtenir le bel aspect
d'aujourd'hui que personne ne remet en
question aujourd'hui donc on a le même
problème donc je suis assez confiant
qu'on va y arriver c'est la gestion du
changement et alors il ya un truc qui
est nouveau c'est que finalement
l'argent hélas
le savoir pfr il n'est pas vraiment là
encore on a beaucoup de paysagiste est
pas encore vraiment des vrais
professionnels de la piste cyclable et
ça ça reste à construire en france et
puis et puis
l'acceptation par les citoyens elle est
à construire en même temps donc en même
temps que les citoyens se mettront à
vélo la part modale pour versailles elle
est de l'ordre de 3% elle augmente tout
doucement on espère quand même 10 20 30
% donc il s'agit d'augmenter la part
modale et pas que du vélo c'est aussi
lui usage
des fauteuils roulants sur les pmr aussi
en droit à la piste cyclable normalement
ils auront le droit les eaux des pme et
des petites télés les trottinettes
et donc nous ça ça fait quand même de la
mobilité qui va vouloir une ligne lourde
de transport en termes d'efficacité et
ça c'est quand même très bien est ce à
cause de la résilience parce que quand
vous avez une grève une panne le vélo il
est pas encore merci à guy carlier merci
feel good and avoir parlé de ce sujet le
rer vélo d'ailleurs un toutes les
informations sur ce projet sont à
retrouver sur le site internet qui va à
sa fiche et ça y est lui s'affiche le
site du rer vélo rer b point fr
à tous merci à vous attention si vous
avez prévu d'emprunter les transports en
commun ce vendredi les syndicats de la
ratp appellent à la grève pour demander
des hausses de salaires conséquence un
trafic fortement perturbé sur toutes les
lignes du réseau dans les yvelines et
rer a et b sont concernés sur les
tronçons ratp prévoyez un train sur deux
en heure de pointe un sur trois en
heures creuses en dehors du créneau 6h30
20h30 les gars seront fermés enfin notez
qu'à paris 8 lignes de métro seront
complètement arrêtées demain les autres
très impacté ce les lignes automatiques
une et 14 fonctionneront normalement
mais une saturation est à prévoir restez
informés sur ratp.fr
[Musique]
toute cette semaine tv 78,2 vous faisait
découvrir les marchés des yvelines
démarche est emblématique
nous refermons ce soir ce dossier à
rambouillet qui accueille près de 100
exposants tous les samedis la première
mention de ce lieu remonte au 14ème
siècle il est aujourd'hui encore
présents place de la libération mais
s'étend aussi à la rue plat du général
de gaulle jusqu'à la place félix faure
découverte avec mélanie poké et célia
tsonga
un peu de calme avant que les clients
viennent en nombre il est 8h et le
marché de rambouillet sanou doucement en
ce matin de février
alors comme l'ail cet été c'est un petit
peu abîmés comme il pleuvait je vous en
mets 2 3 vous sans cadeau pour compenser
la ferme benoît fait partie des plus
anciens commerçants ces maraîchers
viennent tous les mercredis et les
samedis une histoire familiale les
parents de sophie ont un temps suspendu
leur présence en raison d'une trop forte
activité avant de revenir proposer leurs
produits
les enfants ont pris la relève depuis 35
ans on a eu beaucoup de clients il y en
a eu un peu moins malheureusement par
exemple quand le grand frais s'est
installée on l'a ressenti
voilà il ya toujours de la concurrence
un fonds se relever et l'alcôve il faut
se relever mais vous êtes toujours là et
toujours là qu'ils fassent francs comme
aujourd'hui payer moins de clients comme
aujourd'hui mais on est là quand même
la clientèle les gens ont quand même
envie d'acheter s'achète pas de poireaux
une carotte c'est vraiment au fait le
plein pour la famille
ils font de la publicité justement il ya
des fois ils prennent pour des amis pour
des voisins
donc voilà puis c'est des gens avec qui
on peut parler donc c'est il ya une
relation amicale qui se créent en fait
avec le client des anciens mais aussi
des petits nouveaux sur la place de la
mairie par une odeur aller chez les
gourmands et les mal réveillé sont
attirés par un camion merci
c'est important un petit café oui le
matin à c'est très sympa le café le
matin ça c'est sûr et surtout il est
excellent bon arlos koffi est l'un des
derniers exposants installés laura et
arnaud sont présents les samedis depuis
un peu moins d'un an leur particularité
un produit qu'on ne trouve pas souvent
sur les étals d'un marché du café ils
sont artisans torréfacteur c'est notre
plus gros marché on va dire après il ya
le fait qu'on soit qu'on soit en local
on est en bas du coup on est on est sûrs
en bout y est donc donc ça nous tenait à
coeur d'être ici aussi fin c'était
logique on va dire d'être d'être ici et
je pense que les clients le ressentent
aussi le marché de rambouillet il est
très très bien une très bonne ambiance
assez convivial assez familial ici et on
a vraiment notre clientèle fidèle qui
vient vraiment tous les samedis donc
donc on aime beaucoup ce marché du coup
[Musique]
lieu d'achat et lieu de rencontre le
marché de rambouillet est aussi pour les
clients un moment d'échangé de
convivialité
mais du coup tous les amis oui à tous
les samedis je suis au marché à part si
je suis pas là c'est qu'il ya une raison
mais font ça j'ai toujours au marché
j'adore le marché j'ai toujours aimé le
marché
toujours aimé le contact des gens
discussions le dialogue c'est de la
vente qu'on parle
on rencontre du monde les commerçants
sont très sympathiques et puis bon on
trouve des bonnes choses en plus j'ai
habité à rouiller pendant un an et du
coup j'ai mes petites habitudes même si
ça fait très longtemps et j'aime bien
venir ici notamment sur cet état là
jusqu'à 100 commerçants se rassemblent
chaque samedi de 8 heures à 13 heures
pour proposer de nombreux produits aux
clients boucherie charcuterie fromagerie
il n'y en a pour tous les goûts la
commune cherche à le développer au sein
de la future place de la mairie c'est le
plus grand marché du sud du département
deux autres marchés plus intimiste sont
organisées les mercredis et dimanches
elles ont été peintes à achat tout cet
été de fresques font partie des dix plus
belles de france en 2021 une distinction
donnée par le site trompe l'oeil ces
deux oeuvres de la ville des
impressionnistes sont sélectionnés pour
les golden street art l reportage de
justin brasier célia gars de 100 go et
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
6 c'est le nombre de fresques peintes à
chatou en 2021 parmi elles 2 met à
l'honneur la ville des impressionnistes
au golden street art le concours lancé
par trompe-l'oeil point fort est content
cela plus belles fresques réalisées en
france durant l'année écoulée
présélectionné parmi quarante oeuvres de
france elles se sont hissées parmi les
dix finalistes des fresques d'artistes
internationaux comme diversité de vigny
graffiti artiste française to z qui est
jeune qui est de 1982 dont vraiment et
qui a une audience
on va dire internationale puisque ces
fresques sont dans le monde entier et
voilà avec une thématique est bien
particulière c'est ce visage de la jeune
fille quiconque est récurrent sur toutes
ces oeuvres deuxième oeuvre à intégrer
le top 10 celle de carlos alberto
artistes mexicains une fresque en 3d
végétales et animales hier sur le thème
du développement durable
elle habille le mur du collège auguste
renoir il a pris en fait un petit peu
les oiseaux qui assure sur chatou le
martin pêcheur va des agneaux qui ont
retrouvé le résultat est plutôt de
superbes ici à chatou chacun à sa
favorite celle qui est là-bas ou sinon
la petite fresque aussi web ça aussi
c'est très beau il en fait cet été oui
le l'oiseau juste devant
juste devant le collège oui c'est très
beau celle des sabines est qui et sur
les bâtiments orange lab h3c la marianne
si je me trompe pas où c'est une dame en
tout cas qui a dessiné dessus je sais
plus trop mais c'est ça la plus jolie je
trouve ma préférée c'est la jeune fille
qui a dessiné or s'il ya une artiste une
petite artiste qui a dessiné avec des
mots dans les cheveux elle a des cheveux
crépus et des bouclettes vous pouvez
voter pour votre presque préféré sur le
site trompe-l'oeil clôture des votes le
samedi 19 février à 20 heures
avant de refermer ce journal ces images
gabriela à boda directrice musicale de
la maîtrise de trappes a reçu les
insignes de chevalier de l'ordre
national de la légion d'honneur
cérémonie ce mercredi au conservatoire
de musique et de danse de trappes elle a
été décorée notamment pour son
investissement dans l'association pour
la musique de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2010 on les écoute au micro de
nicolas landry ceux-ci super heureuse je
suis très très ému très touché par cette
distinction et c'est la reconnaissance
de la france 2
pas seulement de mon travail parce que
ce que je fais c'est toujours un
réussite d'une équipe donc c'est
valoriser pour les associations l'école
de musique sera de trappes les les
préfets tous ceux qui oeuvrent pour le
bonheur des enfants tout court parce que
chanter c'est du bonheur parce que ça
les élèves parce que ça leur apprend
plein de choses et si on peut participer
à leur épanouissement mais je suis
heureuse l'événement avait commencé par
un moment musical avec les enfants qui
ont interprété de grands classiques
d'ailleurs on se quitte sur ces quelques
notes merci d'avoir suivi ce journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
où
oui
m
[Musique]